hey there folks Chris waters here with
the UB blog at e3 and joined by Michelle
on-cell who was just up on stage at the
ubisoft press conference and that
trailer for Beyond Good and Evil -
Michelle so excited yeah yeah that's
that's a very important moment even in
you know in my long career I've made a
lot of game this is this is great you
know the return of being gone evil after
almost 15 years yeah that's that's
incredible like it's a return that so
many people are excited about myself
included and I bet a lot of you have
questions about that trailer so Michelle
and I are going to sit down go through
the trailer I'm gonna pick his brain
hopefully we'll get you some good tip it
without beyond good and evil - all right
Michelle the trailer starts off and
immediately we get a glimpse of we are
somewhere in the depths of some city
what is this place it's a very vertical
city that's what we wanted to establish
- clearly you and the other thing is
that it's based on the level design of
the game now let's take a look inside
here and can I just say that these
dumplings look delicious I mean did you
purposely try to make them look tasty
they are they are they are very precise
you see a lot of details you it's very
micro you see understood another
seasoning here on top yeah and exactly
but the big idea behind that is that
when you're doing such big games you're
about space it's very important not to
forget about characters about humanity
you know simple things very teeny things
and that's what you can expect you to
see owed on or experienced in this kind
of game and while you travel through
space but your big Johnny crew down into
this kind of changing different
dumplings yeah well speaking of scale
this guy is pretty large yeah yeah the
big try to dominate stir the monkey but
the monkey is very confident has got no
fear and they are talking about master
and slave and domesticated exactly yeah
that's exactly the idea that even
between I breeds that are a mix between
animal and humans
it was a way to establish that there is
a social system in this world and you
can
you're an example here show me the idol
show me the Redeemer ego night I know
I'm not the only one who looked at this
and heard yo don't hide what he said
just there and thought of our beloved
uncle page from Beyond Good and Evil
right there is a there is a direct
connection you know we are we wanted to
UM so is really clearly saying page E
which is a kind of divinity for for this
kind of hybrid it's a way to stoom to
add depth and to just to show how deep
the world can be and even those hybrids
created by humans they have their own
you know a religion and because being
good and evil too is a prequel to being
good and evil one we want to add a lot
of details but how the world is you know
those names page is it a common name you
know divinity name so sometimes you know
in some religion you give the name of a
divinity to a boy or girl or yeah so all
these details are here to make people
understand more how the world of being
good and evil what what what what what
this Swiss [ __ ] chocolate pit and
Knox is out of there he's got that
really cool glove contraption and then
apparently some kind of jet pack to
really help him
yeah make haste yeah and again it's very
important because it's gameplay
ingredients we have in the game so
that's the kind of dynamic you know move
you can do into the game and how you can
extract yourself from very dangerous
situation and then jump and use the
verticality of the city so the pig is
not happy with what's just gone down
obviously and he appears to have
something in his forehead yeah there is
some blood and some pieces of glass that
you know fall on the
on each item how many stars he has -
yeah it's a dis kind of scar very
important because I breeds they have
been created for dangerous tasks that no
you man wanted to do that they can also
be used as fighters you know like I
breed fighting against each others that
there's a lot of slavery so it's another
way to reinforce the depth of the the
world just you know on all this history
that the characters are carrying on the
underbody alright a new character
arrives on the scene in what appears to
be a getaway vehicle so yeah that's
that's shiny she's the crew mate of nuts
they they I used to do this kind of
things all together now this look here
is one of my favorites at the city
because you really start to see those
vertical layers stretching out again
that mixture of ancient architecture but
modern technology here you can see there
are green green gardens at first it was
like more technical things but I really
wanted the city to be spiritual you know
it's like monks are into this kind of
garden there's no advise advertisement
and things like that if you look at
every science and after a certain I'd
it's only religion its and there is this
contrast between very old-style temple
and Allah grams you know so that that's
the kind of idea we wanted to establish
Knox is firing up the back while Shawnee
drives is this an experience that
players are going to be able to sort of
to have in a game and share yes exactly
it's a really something that very button
for our games that you can play online
and the vehicles are made so that you
have different you know places into the
vehicle so on different role and I
really like this kind of dynamic when
you're playing with someone blowing big
stuff up confirmed for beyond been able
to yeah and and here we discuss that a
lot too because if you look they're
breaking a very special part of the
buildings so not the whole city is going
to be a Break ever because it's
technically just impossible to break
this part of the building is made of
glass and things like that that's the
part that is broken
in the real game you have things you can
breakfast you can break and I want that
to be abuse for four people so they're
breaking this big glass part of the the
temple okay but if this planet is not
all one big city here we are out in the
what appears to be the countryside we're
seeing some terrain these isolated
temples there's going to be a lot of
exploration on the planet yeah not just
planets but also space because the
technology here that we have housed
allows us to go seamlessly between
ground interiors and space there's no
transition no loadings nothing like that
Shani and Knox are not alone not a lone
pair they have a whole crew here who is
excited to see them back yeah that again
this is very very important in being
good and evil - you have spaceships of
different sizes as a player you can have
a very very big spaceship and you can
use it as a garage with you other
spaceships and you also have a crew and
the other thing here which is very
important is that it's very cozy
you know it's look like like the
interior of a house I also noticed that
among the human characters we've got a
few more hybrids as part of the crew
yeah exactly every member of the team
has a role a very clear role and here we
wanted to to showcase the the fact that
they are different because somehow
animals and our humans and that bit
message be behind that trailer is that
whatever is your skin color origin if
you are an eye breed whatever you are
you are part of the same team you know
and you will you will share the
adventure and that's that's a very
important message for us and that's
exactly the the heart of being good and
evil well said
yeah and if that heart comes through
that is a really sweet PC casemod yes
here we wanted to connect with being
good and evil one you know where've you
have the what we call the M disk it was
a way to you know in even if it's a
futuristic world you still have object
that contains data and here the data are
inside of the what we call the BAI of
the spaceship so here this
skill is in fact the character that
represents that is the spaceship like in
Beyond Good and Evil one she's got a bag
and there is a guy into the bag kind of
computer you know speaking with her
that's exactly the same ID but nights
the spaceship that is able to speak he
is not speaking but so the question is
what's on the disk a map exactly a map
with a mysterious artifact in the middle
of it and also a dead guy exactly that
that was a good map should be you know
it's attracting you you want to you want
to travel to this direction but it's
going to be dangerous others did it
before they died spaceships get
destroyed and if you look in the
background there is even a planet that
is going to be your destroyed by this
magnetic fields very powerful and I
don't want to say too much things about
that now I don't want to spoil anything
about the game that's a nice color green
and those eyes what's another word for
like a greenish color would you say
maybe it's also a precious metal of some
kind yes I see what you mean very
clearly and again that's the connection
we've been good and evil one you the
jade color and but but again we don't
want to spoil the story we don't want to
do shortcuts about that but yes that
they are connections clearly and then
the main theme of good and evil one mmm
along with one final surprise this is a
huge spaceship and you are taking to the
stars super quick yes but um the reveal
of the spaceship and the fact that we
started with this very dark place you
know with this very small restaurant a
lot of detail small things and done its
opening to something very large and
that's an idea and that trailer is that
okay now Beyond Good and Evil 2 is back
it's back for true it's it's here the
game is going to be huge
Michelle thank you so much for talking
through the trailer sharing more about
Beyond Good and Evil 2 I'm so excited
honestly to go back and watch the tree
again because I feel like there's even
more stuff I might've missed I love you
can't imagine there's a lot of
information about the world but there's
also Easter eggs oh yeah yeah yeah and
it could be very very cool if people try
to identify them you know find them they
can connect to our website they can
share about those Easter eggs between
each other so everybody can come yes
join what we call our space monkey
program which is letting people enter
the development you know discussing with
us and making being good evil as cool as
possible